-Let's get to the news.
President Biden visited
an Amtrak maintenance facility
today in Delaware.
So we got an extra hour
of sleep this weekend,
but he sure didn't.
"I'm too excited."
Former President Trump
took the witness stand today
in his civil fraud trial.
He swore to tell the truth,
the whole truth and nothing
but the truth,
and then everyone
just laughed and laughed.
While testifying during his
civil fraud trial today,
former President Trump said
that he believes
his Mar-a-Lago resort
is worth between
$1 billion and $1.5 billion.
Oh. Very smart.
The insanity defense.
Dude, you bought it
for $10,000,000 in 1985,
and now it's worth 1.5 billion?
The only way I would believe
that is if it was in Brooklyn.
Then that's about right.
Maybe a little low.
While testifying today,
former President Trump
also appeared to forget
that he wasn't president
in 2021.
Well, so did half the country.
After FBI agents raided the home
of his chief fundraiser
last week,
New York Mayor Eric Adams said,
quote,
"Where there's smoke,
there's not always fire."
Ah, yes,
that famous expression.
Okay, so we found out
he's shady.
But you know what they say --
late is worse than never.
The third Republican
presidential primary debate
will be held Wednesday in Miami
or, as it's now dubbed,
"Who Wants to Be
a Vice President?"
Pennsylvania Senator
John Fetterman
criticized California Governor
Gavin Newsom over the weekend
and said he was secretly
running for president,
as opposed to Fetterman,
who looks like
he's running for
guy who doesn't wipe down
the equipment at the gym.
Meta CEO Mark Zuckerberg
revealed on Friday
that he tore his ACL
while training
for a competitive MMA fight.
Apparently,
what happened was
there was a coffee table
in the way.
The fastest runner in
the New York City Marathon
yesterday
finished the course
in just under two hours
and five minutes,
a full ten minutes faster
than if he had taken the bus.
Better luck next year, the bus.
Archeologists in Germany believe
they've discovered
the ancient remains
of a husband and wife
buried in the same casket.
Her idea.
[ Laughter ]
Baz!
We're going to win them back
with this one.
And finally, the American
Ornithological -- Ornith--
Oh, Jesus.
I said this word wrong
last week,
and I got a lot of angry notes
from ornithologists.
And now I'm in my head about it.
And finally, the American
Bird People Society
announced --
It's fine.
It's an either/or.
It's famously an either/or.
Announced last week that it
is renaming birds
that are currently named
after problematic people,
though in retrospect,
it was never really fair
to name that one
Jared from Subway.
Former president Trump
testified yesterday
at his civil fraud trial
and spent nearly four hours
on the witness stand.
But the judge
had to call it a day
before they could ask him
a third question.
[ Laughter ]
During his testimony yesterday,
former president Trump
pulled a piece of paper
out of his suit jacket
that he claimed
would clear his name,
but the judge would not
let him read it
'cause, as usual,
it was classified.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
during his civil fraud trial,
Trump pulled a piece of paper
out of his suit jacket
and said it would
completely clear his name.
Dude, you couldn't have
cleared your name
if you'd pulled out a neuralyzer
from "Men in Black."
What piece of paper
could possibly clear your name?
Was it a birth certificate
with a different name?
[ As Trump ] Your Honor,
this clears my name because,
as you can see,
my name is Reginald Periwinkle.
You've got the wrong guy.
[ Normal voice ] Ivanka Trump
is set to testify tomorrow
as part of the civil fraud trial
against former president Trump,
marking -- making it, excuse me,
the first thing she's been
invited to in New York
in eight years.
[ Laughter ]
Democrats -- Have her
over to your house.
Feel so bad about it.
Democrats reportedly
have concerns
about President Biden's
reelection campaign
and are worried that
his political advisers
are ignoring warning signs
of sinking support.
Said Biden, "There's nothing
to worry about, right, Jill?
Jill?!"
Amid reports that he has
declined an invitation
to attend King Charles's
75th birthday party,
a spokesperson for Prince Harry
said that he never
received an invite,
or, more likely,
Meghan got the mail that day.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, let me tell you something.
I don't think either
of them get the mail.
[ Laughter ]
Elon Musk's brain implant
company, Neuralink,
has announced that
it's looking for volunteers
for human testing.
Well, actually, what they said
was "fresh volunteers."
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Musk's brain implant company
has announced it's looking for
volunteers for human testing.
I don't think he should be
meddling with something
he doesn't really understand,
like humans.
[ Laughter ]
The co-work--
I love what he did with Twitter.
I'd love to get him
up in my brain.
[ Laughter ]
Love to get him up there
to fiddle around.
Now it's not called
the brain anymore.
It's called B.
[ Laughter ]
The co-working space
company WeWork
filed yesterday for bankruptcy.
Wait a minute.
Again?
You already went
out of business.
I watched a whole miniseries
about how you went
out of business,
and you were still in business?
Oh, my God, Trump's going to win
again, isn't he?
According to a new study,
daily marijuana use
could increase the risk
of a heart attack.
And that's why I only
smoke it nightly.
[ Laughter ]
Using my B.
The CDC announced yesterday
it will expand
its airport disease
surveillance program
to include
more than 30 pathogens.
Cool. I think I know where
you can find 27 of them.
[ Audience groans ]
The makers --
You guys all got feet.
[ Laughter ]
Everybody's like, "Oh, feet,
a human foot.
I would never."
The makers of M&M's
have unveiled
a new holiday flavor,
Toasty Vanilla,
which features
white chocolate candies
coated in brown,
white, and vanilla shell.
It's the holiday treat
that will have everyone saying,
"Do you have any normal ones?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally, according
to the latest numbers,
Taylor Swift's new album
"1989 (Taylor's Version)"
has sold 1.6 million units
in the U.S.,
and it's made her
almost 8 cents on Spotify.
[ Cheers and applause ]
According to a new poll,
President Biden's approval
rating dropped to 39%.
But he's thinking
he can get that back up
once he's indicted a few times.
President Biden participated
in yesterday's
White House Demo Day,
showcasing new technologies
from across the country,
and was way
too easily impressed.
"Sir,
that's the office printer."
"Look at this thing."
Former President Trump
praised his daughter Ivanka
this morning ahead of her
taking the witness stand
at his civil fraud trial
and called her, "my wonderful
and beautiful daughter."
Weird,
when his sons were testifying,
he didn't have much
to say about them,
but now that it's Ivanka,
he's talking to her
like she has medical power
of attorney over him.
"My wonderful
and beautiful daughter
would never pull the plug
on her sick father.
I could recover.
A lot of people
are saying I could recover."
Ahead of Ivanka Trump's
testimony today,
former President Trump
complained in a post
on Truth Social that the judge
and state prosecutors
were, "making me look bad."
And then he sprayed
his face bronze,
combed his ear hair
to the center of his head,
yanked his tie down
to his knees,
and left the house for the day.
During a hearing yesterday
of the UK's official
coronavirus inquiry,
a former aide said
that then-Prime Minister
Boris Johnson
had asked at the start
of the pandemic
to be injected with Covid-19
live on television.
Way too risky,
said his advisers,
about putting him
live on television.
The Boris Johnson photo
just getting laughs.
Just getting laughs.
It's good every now
and then when you go,
"Yeah, we're not the only one
who had one of those."
They had -- Other people
had one of those.
Texas Senator Ted Cruz
said in a new interview
that he plans to run
for president again someday
and added, "I loved
running for president in 2016.
We came incredibly close.
We came within inches
of winning."
I guess in the same way
that the moon
is within 16 billion inches
of the Earth.
Texas Senator Ted Cruz released
his new book yesterday titled,
"Unwoke" How to Defeat
Cultural Marxism in America."
And if you really want
to be unwoke,
he also reads the audiobook.
[ Laughter ]
New York Mets owner Steve Cohen
yesterday unveiled his plans
for a new casino,
hotel, and music venue
near Citi Field,
which is expected
to cost $8 billion,
or roughly $1 billion
times as much as
the average Mets ticket
in September.
So much math in that joke.
Not just math,
but then calendar.
To get that punch line,
you had to do math,
then you had to do calendar,
then you had to do baseball.
I can't believe it went
as well as it did.
"People" magazine
announced yesterday
that it has named actor
Patrick Dempsey
The Sexiest Man Alive.
[ Cheers ]
You guys know we were
only supposed to set our clocks
back one hour, right?
I will say,
I read that joke first,
and then I saw a picture
and I'm like,
"Pretty [bleep] sexy."
I'm not complaining
about the pick.
And finally, three pandas from
the Smithsonian National Zoo
were returned to China today,
packed in a special crate
on a FedEx plane --
or as Southwest calls it,
Economy Plus.
President Biden and
Chinese President Xi Jinping
are reportedly
prepared to announce
the return of
the direct military hotline.
And this is fun --
they're letting
Biden pick the phone.
The third Republican
presidential debate
was held last night in Miami.
What's the point?
It's like going to a NSync
concert without Justin.
We don't know the rest of you!
During the first few minutes
of last night's debate,
moderator Lester Holt
admonished the crowd
several times for
cheering and applauding,
saying, "Let's not do this."
Man, you know our political
decorum is in bad shape
when the moderator has to
talk to the audience
like they're his ex-wife.
"Can we not do this today,
Bethany?
I'm just here
to drop off the kids."
During last night's debate,
Vivek Ramaswamy criticized
Nikki Haley's
foreign policy views
and said she was,
"Dick Cheney in 3-inch heels."
"Hey, I'm right here,"
said Ron DeSantis.
After Vivek Ramaswamy criticized
Nikki Haley's daughter for using
TikTok during
last night's debate,
Haley told Ramaswamy to,
"Keep my daughter's name
out of your voice."
And even though he was
thousands of miles away,
Chris Rock instinctively ducked.
During last night's debate,
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
said that voters
shouldn't support
former President Trump in 2024,
and added that he's a "different
guy than he was in 2016."
Of course, thanks to Trump,
we're all different guys
than we were in 2016.
"Politico"
published an article today
after last night's
debate titled,
"Tim Scott's Girlfriend
is in fact, Real.
However, Jury's Still Out
on Tim Scott."
According to a new report,
the quality of the
in-flight food onboard
Air Force Two has improved.
Oh, you mean
since Mike Pence used it?
The guy who thinks
oregano is a sin?
He threw away the beverage cart
when that Sprite
gave him a hangover.
The FBI and Italian authorities
announced yesterday
they arrested 17 men
allegedly connected
with the Gambino crime family
on charges
including mafia association
and arson,
though officials say
it could still be weeks
before Netflix is able to
release a show about it.
A bear in Florida recently stole
a $45 Taco Bell order
from the front porch of a home.
Wait a minute.
How do you spend $45
at Taco Bell?
What did you order?
All of it?
And finally, the FDA
has launched an investigation
into counterfeit versions
of the weight loss drug Ozempic.
Users first became suspicious
when they noticed Wilma.
That was a monologue,
everybody!
♪♪